DO THAT.
IF HE IS THE RNC NOMINEE, DO YOU
INTEND TO VOTE FOR HIM?
>> I HAVE ANSWERED THAT QUESTION
IN WAY.
I AM ONE OF THOSE REPUBLICANS
WHO HOPES THE FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP DOESN'T RUN.
IN ALL FAIRNESS, WE DON'T NEED
HIM ANY MORE.
HE CHANGED OUR PARTY.
WE HAVE A LOT OF FOLKS, A NEW
GENERATION OF FOLKS, RON
DeSANTIS, MIKE PENCE, MIKE
POMPEO, GO DOWN THE LIST OF
FOLKS WHO COULD GIVE US THE SAME
THAT DONALD TRUMP GAVE WITHOUT
THE BAGGAGE.
AS A REPUBLICAN I AM THINKING IF
THE ELECTION WERE TODAY AND JOE
BIDEN WAS THE NOMINEE FOR THE
DEMOCRATS OR KAMALA HARRIS OR
GAVIN NEWSOME, THERE IS ONE
MAINSTREAM REPUBLICAN WHO COULD
LOSE AND THAT'S DONALD TRUMP.
KNOWING WHAT I KNOW, I WOULD BE
HARD PRESSED TO SUPPORT DONALD
TRUMP AGAIN.
>> OBVIOUSLY, YOUR THOUGHT OF
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY NO LONGER
NEEDING DONALD TRUMP MIGHT NOT
BE THE VIEW OF MILLIONS WHO
VOTED FOR HIM AS PART OF HIS
BASE.
IF HE ULTIMATELY DECIDES I
INTEND TO RUN AND NONE OF THE
OTHER PEOPLE COULD, YOU WILL
HAVE QUITE A CHOICE ON YOUR
HANDS WHETHER TO --
>> KEEP IN MIND, I THINK WE
MOVED BEYOND DONALD TRUMP
CLEARING THE FIELD.
I THINK THAT IS ONE THING THAT
THE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE HAS
ACCOMPLISHED.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S WHAT THEY
WANTED TO ACCOMPLISH.
I THOUGHT THEY WANTED TO BRING
CRIMINAL CHARGES OR ENCOURAGE
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO
BRING CRIMINAL CHARGES.
TO THE EXTENT THEY WANTED TO
WOUND HIM POLITICALLY, I THINK
THAT HAPPENED.
THERE IS BEEN POLLING DATA
RECENTLY FOR THE FIRST TIME SAYS
THAT A MAJORITY OF REPUBLICAN
PRIMARY VOTERS WOULD PREFER
SOMEBODY OTHER THAN DONALD
TRUMP.
THAT'S A BIG CHANGE OVER THE
COURSE EVER THE LAST SIX OR
EIGHT WEEKS.
EIGHT WEEKS AGO I DOUBT VERY
SERIOUSLY ANY TOP TIER
REPUBLICANS, AGAIN PENCE,
POMPEO, TIM SCOTT, DeSANTIS WERE
CONSIDERING RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT.
I THINK NOW MANY OF THEM ARE.
I THINK NIKKI HALEY TODAY HINTED
SHE MIGHT RUN IN A SPEECH SHE
GAVE IN ISRAEL.
I THINK THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
HAS CHANGED OVER THE COURSE OF
THE LAST SIX WEEKS, EIGHT WEEKS,
AND CHANGED BECAUSE OF THE
COMMITTEE.
I THINK THEY WERE OUT TO SORT OF
GET HIM AND TRY TO THROW HIM IN
JAIL, I DON'T THINK THAT WAS
GOING TO HAPPEN.
I DON'T THINK IT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN BASED O